Speaker 1: All right.
We predicted yesterday and it was so obvious.
This is, as I say many times, this is not
like a pat on the back, that this was some
amazing prediction.
It was obvious that now that the Pfizer covid
vaccine is FDA approved, you were going to
start hearing from the right saying, I don't
know that we can trust this approval.
This may have been rushed.
The Biden administration may have accelerated
it when it really shouldn't have been approved
yet or whatever the case may be.
Now, why is this relevant?
This is relevant again, because I only you
know, I know that the right is now just about
owning the Libs.
I don't care about crap like that, OK?
What I want is let's get people vaccinated
so the excuse can start emptying out and so
that we have room in hospitals for people
who get into a car accident, get hurt at work,
whatever the case may be, that my priority
is health.
OK, one third of those who were resisting
the vaccine said if and when there is a full
approval, then I will go and get vaccinated.
So that's a really important thing.
So we care about how media and the right reacts
to news of the approval.
Here is a Fox News segment that opens yesterday
by saying, was it rushed or was it rushed?
Take a listen to
Speaker 2: a Fox News alert for you.
Now, the FDA just giving full approval to
Pfizer's Kobad vaccine.
It's the first vaccine to get that full approval
and in record time, too, that has critics
asking if the process was rushed.
Was it?
Well, let's bring in Admiral Bradshaw now.
Speaker 1: OK, there are people who said it's
unfair to show only that because Dr. Brett
Jira comes in and says, no, it's safe.
I agree with you, but it's still teasing it.
You're leading with that.
And it's Fox News and you know the audience.
Now, Dr. Brett Jarah comes in and he says
it's safe.
But notice that 40 seconds later, the other
anchor, Bill Hemmer, is going to say, by the
way, what took so long?
Wait a second.
Was it rushed or did it take too long?
Which is it?
Why can't you guys decide?
Speaker 2: Health and Human Services assistant
secretary.
And of course, he was our testing czar.
So tell us a little bit, sir, about what this
moment means to get full approval, sir?
Speaker 3: Well, this is a very big moment
in operation warp speed history in the history
of our vaccines, our fight against the pandemic.
Prior to this, we had emergency use authorization.
What that really meant is that the public
health benefits outweighed the known and potential
harms.
This says today, as we know the benefits,
we know the harms.
And this vaccine is safe and effective.
And every confidence can be given to that.
Americans should feel very good, even better
than they did yesterday about getting the
vaccine.
What took so long?
Speaker 4: Oh, man.
Speaker 1: The critics are worried this was
done too quickly.
It was it was it done too quickly?
No, absolutely not.
Oh, what took so long to get this approved?
Come on, guys.
So let's listen to a little bit more.
Speaker 3: Well, it is a complicated process.
And I know there are many, many good professionals,
incredible professionals at the FDA.
I was acting commissioner.
It does take a while because all the data
is looked at in detail.
Pages turn, the facilities are inspected.
However, again, as I've said before, I think
it's unconscionable that the Biden administration
does not have an FDA commissioner even nominated
to provide leadership.
It might have been a little faster, but it
is complicated.
There's a lot of material and Americans should
feel very confident in the process.
Speaker 2: Some have said that they were hesitant
to get the vaccine and pointed to this lack
of full approval.
How do you think the administration and its
goal to try to get more people vaccinated
can utilize this news?
Speaker 3: Well, I think the American people
will utilize the news.
The polls said about 30 percent of those who
have not been vaccinated.
Right.
Would become vaccinated, feel very confident
about that once the vaccine received full
approval.
That just happened.
The vaccine is fully approved.
And I am very hopeful that this will push
people over the edge to go get the vaccine
because it is OK.
Speaker 1: So you guys get the point.
So so listen, the full video shows the guests
saying it wasn't rushed and people should
get the vaccine.
That's a very good thing.
That's good.
The framing up front and the fact that Fox
still cedes the talking point, was it rushed?
Can we trust it?
Their first instinct is to lead the segment
with can we really even trust this approval,
which is already what many Fox News viewers
are prone to believe.
Can we really trust this?
And so I get that just the first 12 seconds
were floating around yesterday and there were
people saying it's dishonest to say that the
entire segment meant to tell people that it
was rushed.
You're right.
And there were some people who only played
the first 12 seconds.
I've played the full two minutes.
OK, you're right.
Bret Gira says it's safe and it wasn't rushed.
I played the rest and I'm glad that that's
what the guest said.
But this is a channel whose audience lives
in 15 second soundbites, many of whom want
to believe it was rushed and many of whom
will see that question asked.
And the rest of the stuff doesn't matter.
And so this is really important.
Breacher cited the same study I've been citing.
One third of the vaccine resistant have said
resistant maybe is not a good word because
it means something else of the vaccine.
Hesitant have said if there's full approval,
I will go and get vaccinated.
Let's now see if they do.
We'll have more coverage of the reaction from
right wing media to the full approval later
on in the show and also on The David Pakman
Show Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show